A quick note before we start, this episode includes sounds of shootings from a college campus. It also features music with violent and explicit language. If you're listening with small kids, you may want to save this one for later. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On a chilly April morning in 2007, a nightmare unfolded on a college campus in Virginia. A 23-year-old student acting alone opened fire in a dormitory. He shot and killed two students. Then he walked across campus and began killing people in an engineering building. The sound of gunfire
在开始之前先做个简短说明，本期节目包含大学校园枪击案的枪声，还包含带有暴力和粗俗语言的音乐。如果您正和幼小的孩子一起收听，或许可以稍后听这期。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。2007年4月的一个寒冷早晨，一场噩梦在弗吉尼亚州的一所大学校园里上演。一名23岁的学生独自在宿舍开枪。他枪杀了两名学生。然后他穿过校园，开始在一栋工程大楼里杀人。枪声
was caught on a student's cell phone. We weren't sure what it was. It was gunshots, but for a while we thought it would have been construction. We heard this horrible scream and laughter. Tina Harrison was a student in the building. So we were sitting in the classroom and basically panic broke out. All we could hear was people screaming, laughter, and more screaming. And I counted 24 gunshots within a minute and I lost track after that. I just started praying. By the time the assault ended, 32 people were dead.
被一名学生的手机录了下来。“我们不确定那是什么。那是枪声，但有一段时间我们以为是施工。我们听到可怕的尖叫声和笑声。”蒂娜·哈里森是该大楼的一名学生。“所以我们当时坐在教室里，恐慌基本上爆发了。我们能听到的只有人们的尖叫声、笑声，还有更多的尖叫声。我在一分钟内数了24声枪响，之后我就记不清了。我当时只想祈祷。”当袭击结束时，已有32人死亡。
The gunman took his own life. The shooting at Virginia Tech was quickly seared into our minds as one of the deadliest mass shootings in US history. The news media tried to convey the sheer scale of the massacre. There is terror and then sorrow today at the campus of Virginia Tech. An act of evil on a scale that we've never seen in this country before. Four hours after the news began to break, blackspread Virginia is still in shock from its wounds. But even as the country mourned, people began to ask why campus officials hadn't been more proactive. Why hadn't they spotted the warning signs? Why hadn't they locked down the school after the first shooting at the dorm?
枪手随后自杀。弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案迅速深深刻在我们脑海中，成为美国历史上最致命的大规模枪击案之一。新闻媒体试图传达这场屠杀的巨大规模。“弗吉尼亚理工大学校园今天充满了恐惧和悲 sorrow。这是一场我们这个国家前所未见的邪恶行径。”在新闻开始播报四小时后，弗吉尼亚理工大学仍沉浸在枪击带来的创伤和震惊之中。然而，正当全国上下沉浸在悲痛之中时，人们开始质问为什么校园官员没有采取更多的主动防范措施。为什么他们没有发现这些危险信号？为什么在宿舍发生第一起枪击事件后，学校没有封锁校园？
At a press conference, campus police tried to explain. We had information from witnesses and the evidence at the scene that led us to believe the shooter was no longer in the building and more likely off campus. Reporter's grilled officials, who at times seemed lost for words. Can you outline your blackout policy for the university? Are you saying that do we have a policy to walk down the campus? Yeah, I'm like, when? Under what circumstances can do it? What's your time right now? I don't think so. It It's not the mic communication plan. Eventually, the state of Virginia and the university
在一次新闻发布会上，校园警察试图做出解释。“我们根据目击者的信息和现场证据，认为枪手已经不在大楼里，更有可能已经离开校园。”记者们对官员们进行了严厉质问，而官员们有时似乎无言以对。“你能概述一下你们大学的宵禁或封锁政策吗？你是说我们有封锁校园的政策吗？对，我的意思是，什么时候？在什么情况下可以这么做？你现在的时间是……我不这么认为。这不是信息沟通计划。”最终，弗吉尼亚州和该大学
paid victims' families more than $11 million to settle lawsuits. Across the nation, universities cramble to improve their security protocols. Many added expensive upgrades to emergency alert systems and hired new police officers to stay on top of possible danger. Awareness to cold on college campuses. A subtle fear was in the air, a low grade buzz of anxiety. People weren't taking chances. At schools like Southern Illinois University in Edwardsville, small things that were out of place led to intense scrutiny. His car was discovered, parked in a very
向受害者家属支付了超过1100万美元以达成诉讼和解。在全美各地，各大高校争相改进其安全协议。许多学校为紧急警报系统增加了昂贵的升级，并聘请了新的警务人员来防范潜在的危险。大学校园里对冷酷事件的警惕性提高了。空气中弥漫着一种微妙的恐惧，一种低强度的焦虑情绪。人们不敢心存侥幸。在爱德华兹维尔的南伊利诺伊大学等学校，一些不寻常的小事也会引起密切关注。“他的车被发现停在爱德华兹维尔这里大学的一个非常显眼、非常不寻常的禁停车位里。”他们发现，你知道，车里显眼处放着一张便条。
conspicuous, very unusual, no parking area at the University here in Edwardsville. And they found, you know, visible in the car, a note. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore a complicated case that unfolded in the months after the Virginia Tech shooting. It was so complicated that even today, years later, people still disagree about what really happened. At the heart of the case was this question, how can we know, really know, what's happening inside another person's head?
本周的“隐藏的大脑”，我们探讨了一个复杂的案件，它发生在弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案发生几个月后。这个案子非常复杂，以至于时至今日，多年过去了，人们对当时究竟发生了什么仍然争论不休。这个案件的核心在于这样一个问题：我们怎么能知道，真正知道另一个人的脑子里在想什么？
Perception, reality, and judgment, this week on Hidden Brain. Three months after the Virginia Tech Massacre, an Illinois gun dealer picked up the phone and called a federal bureau of alcohol, tobacco and firearms. He told an agent that he was worried about a client who was trying to purchase guns. It was the first time he'd ever made a report to the ATF and I think about 10 years of being a gun seller, a gun dealer. Tom Gibbons is the Madison County Illinois State's attorney. Tom says the man who'd contacted the gun dealer was agitated and adamant. He said he needed the guns quickly.
感知、现实与判断，本周“隐藏的大脑”。弗吉尼亚理工大学大屠杀发生三个月后，伊利诺伊州的一名枪械经销商拿起电话，打给了联邦烟酒枪炮及爆裂物管理局（ATF）。他告诉一名探员，他担心一个试图购买枪支的客户。这是他在做枪械销售员大约十年里，第一次向ATF进行举报。汤姆·吉本斯是伊利诺伊州麦迪逊县的州检察官。汤姆说，联系枪械经销商的那个人情绪激动且态度坚决。他说他急需这些枪。
And what he was purchasing was unusual. He was buying three low-cost, exact same models of a gun, semi-automatic handgun, a 380 caliber. The gun dealer explained that the man, whose name was Oletosun Odeuale, had purchased the gun's wholesale on the internet and needed him a licensed transfer agent to complete the transaction. Oletosun's background check was clean, but the Gandhilev felt something wasn't right.
而且他购买的东西很不寻常。他买的是三支低成本、完全相同型号的枪，一把半自动手枪，380口径。枪械经销商解释说，这个名叫奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱（Oletosun Odeuale）的人是通过互联网批发购买这些枪支的，并需要他这位持牌枪械过户代理商来完成这笔交易。奥莱托孙的背景调查没有任何问题，但这位枪械经销商总觉得哪里不对劲。
The ATF suspected Oletosin might possibly be its tropurgicir, someone buying guns for someone else. But Tom Gibbon says, police also considered more sinister motives. Having three identical weapons, if a person's going to do something harmful or commit a mass casualty event, having three identical firearms has the advantage of being able to use the identical ammunition to use the exact same magazines with that ammunition no matter which of the guns you're using, and of course buying low-cost multiple weapons allows you to have multiple weapons available at a single time. The ATF quickly learned that Oluhtosin was a student at Southern Illinois University.
ATF怀疑奥莱托孙可能是一个“代购枪支者”（straw purchaser），即替别人买枪的人。但汤姆·吉本斯表示，警方也考虑了更恶劣的动机。“拥有三把相同的武器，如果一个人要做有害的事情或实施大规模伤亡事件，拥有三把相同的枪支的好处是，无论你使用哪支枪，都可以使用相同的弹药、使用完全相同的弹药弹匣，当然，购买低成本的多把武器可以让你在同一时间拥有多把武器。”ATF很快了解到，奥莱托孙是南伊利诺伊大学的一名学生。
The ATF contacted the local police department and they began to look into it. According to documents later filed in court, the ATF agent also called campus police detective Rick Weisenborn. The ATF gave the detective a heads up that Oletosan had ordered weapons over the internet. Rick Weisenborn wrote a memo to his colleague that advised them to use caution if they encountered the young man. Two days later a police officer on a routine campus patrol came across an unattended car. He alerted Rick Weisenborn who went to investigate. Police traced the license plate to Oletosun, Odehuale. His car was discovered, parked in a very conspicuous,
ATF联系了当地警察局，他们开始对此展开调查。根据后来提交给法庭的文件，ATF探员还打电话给校园警察侦探里克·维森伯恩（Rick Weisenborn）。ATF向这位侦探发出预警，称奥莱托孙通过互联网订购了武器。里克·维森伯恩写了一份备忘录给他的同事，建议他们在遇到这名年轻时要保持谨慎。两天后，一名在校园进行例行巡逻的警察偶然发现了一辆无人看管的汽车。他向里克·维森伯恩发出了警报，后者随即前去调查。警方通过车牌查到了车主是奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱。他的车被发现停在一个非常显眼、
a very unusual, no-parking area at the university here in Edwardsville. Police monitored the vehicle to see if anyone approached it. For two days, Rick Weisenborn drove past the car himself. No one showed up. The detective notified his supervisor. Campus police were authorized to tour a vehicle that had been left unattended for more than 24 hours. So when his car was being towed, it was the department police department policy that the car is inventoryed. They take an inventory of the contents and they found, you know, visible in the car, a note.
非常不寻常的、爱德华兹维尔大学的禁停车位里。警方对这辆车进行了监控，看是否有人靠近它。整整两天，里克·维森伯恩自己开车经过这辆车。没有人出现。侦探通知了他的上司。校园警察有权拖走停放超过24小时无人看管的车辆。因此，当他的车被拖走时，这是警察局的政策规定，即对车辆进行清点。他们对车内的物品进行了清点，然后他们发现，你知道，车里显眼处放着一张便条。
It was protruding from underneath the center console. It had writing on both sides, on one side, what seemed like rap lyrics. Turn the page over, and there were more lyrics. Tom says they read like this. And you may have to bleep some of this out. I lead she a follower. I'm single and not with her, but she got a throat deeper than a sword swallower. For the down on the page was more writing. Tom says these send two dollars to, and then it's a PayPal account.
它从中心控制台下方露出来。两面都有字，一面看起来像说唱歌词。翻到背面，还有更多的歌词。汤姆说它们读起来是这样的。“你可能得把其中一些消音。”“我带头，她随从。我单身，跟她没关系，但她喉咙深处比吞剑的还深。”页面下方还有更多文字。汤姆说这些写着：“把两美元寄到……”然后是一个PayPal账户。
If the money doesn't reach $50,000 in the next seven days, then a murderous rampage similar to the Virginia Tech shooting will occur at another highly populated university, and then in all capital letters, this is not a joke. Police didn't take it as one. Detective Rick Weisenborn took photos of the vehicle while snapping pictures of the back seat he noticed release straps and pulled them to lower the seat backs. He found a water clothing.
“如果在接下来的七天里，资金没有达到5万美元，那么另一所人口密集的大学将发生类似于弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案的血腥大屠杀。”接着全部是大写字母：“这不是个玩笑。”警方并没有把它当成玩笑。侦探里克·维森伯恩给这辆车拍了照，在拍后座照片时，他注意到了释放带并拉动它们以放倒靠背。他发现了一套衣服。
There was a long sleeve shirt, a short sleeve shirt, and a knit cap with a ski mask. The detective seized all of it. Officers also found six rounds of 25 caliber ammunition in the car. They felt they needed to act fast. It was pretty early in the morning, I remember, and I just got out of the shower. This is Thomas Phillips, the third. He was Oletoan Odeoale's roommate that summer. He remembers a loud pounding on the door. And there was about eight police officers standing there. Thomas was asked to step out of the room. Police told Oletosan he was under arrest. Oletosan was wearing basketball shorts and a tank top.
有一件长袖衬衫、一件短袖衬衫，还有一顶带滑雪面罩的针织帽。侦探把这些全部扣押了。警官们还在车里发现了六发25口径的子弹。他们觉得必须迅速采取行动。“那是清晨，我记得我刚洗完澡。”这是第三个托马斯·菲利普斯（Thomas Phillips, the third）。那年夏天他是奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱的室友。他记得门被狠狠地敲响了。外面大约站了八名警察。托马斯被要求离开房间。警察告诉奥莱托孙他被捕了。奥莱托孙当时穿着篮球短裤和背心。
He didn't have shoes on. They cuffed him, they had his hands behind his back, and he didn't look my way when he came up. I don't also think the heat saw where I was sitting because I was sitting off to the side of the stairs, but they took him out the long way towards the back where they had a car waiting for him. A search of the dorm room uncovered a camcorder, video cassettes, and a Dell laptop computer. Tom Gibbon says there was also something else. A Jennings 25 caliber pistol. The loaded firearm.
他没有穿鞋。他们给他戴上手铐，把他的手反拷在身后，他走过来时没有看我这边。我也不认为警察看到了我坐的地方，因为我坐在楼梯侧面，但他们把他带走了，走的是后面那条远路，那里有一辆车在等着他。对宿舍的搜查发现了一台摄像机、录像带和一台戴尔笔记本电脑。汤姆·吉本斯说，还有别的东西。一把詹宁斯25口径手枪。一把上膛的枪支。
The gun belonged to Oletosan. So let's review. A young man attempts to purchase multiple guns over the internet. His describe is agitated and anxious by a gun dealer involved in the transaction. The ATF launches an investigation. The young man's car is found apparently abandoned on a campus side road. Inside it is a piece of paper with a threat on it, alluding to ransom and a possible massacre
这把枪属于奥莱托孙。我们来回顾一下。一名年轻人试图通过互联网购买多支枪。参与交易的枪械经销商形容他情绪激化且焦虑。ATF启动了调查。这名年轻人的车被发现显然被遗弃在校园旁路。车里有一张写着威胁内容的纸条，暗示勒索以及可能在大学校园里发生的
on a university campus. When the young man is arrested, a loaded gun is discovered in his dorm room. State's attorney Tom Gibbon says police felt they had prevented a serious crime. So connecting the dots, it became apparent that in fact he was planning. He was, if not planning an actual mass casualty event, he was planning to be able to credibly threaten that.
大屠杀。当这名年轻人被捕时，在他的宿舍里发现了一把上膛的枪。州检察官汤姆·吉本斯说，警方认为他们阻止了一起严重的犯罪。“所以把这些线索串联起来，很明显，实际上他正在策划。即使他不是在策划真正的大规模伤亡事件，他也在策划能够做出可信的威胁。”
And he was, he was taking steps, actual steps towards making a terrorist threat. It wasn't long before the news media got a hold of the story. Coming just after the Virginia Tech shooting, the story generated wall-to-wall coverage. Thomas Phillips. For, I'd say about a week's solid, news coverage had its face on CNN, MSNBC, like MSNBC, pretty much any news station you could turn to that had headline news. And he was either the first or second subject of it. That's all we saw in
而且他正在采取实际行动，朝着发出恐怖威胁迈出步伐。没过多久，新闻媒体就掌握了这个故事。由于紧接着弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案发生，这个故事引发了全方位的报道。托马斯·菲利普斯：“我可以说，大约连续一个星期，新闻报道的头条都是他的脸，在CNN、MSNBC，基本上任何你能调到的有滚动新闻的新闻台。他要么是第一条新闻的主题，要么是第二条。这就是我们在新闻里看到的他的全部内容，差不多就是这样。他是个恐怖分子，他策划了整场袭击，他在车里留下了威胁便条，里面有弹药。他买枪是为了资助这次袭击，还是为了执行袭击。”他们展示了一张他从未买到、但实际上想在某个时候购买的枪支表格。事实证明，奥莱托孙实际上从网上订购了四把枪，其中三把是彼此相同的小口径枪支，另一把是45口径的MAC-10冲锋枪。州检察官汤姆·吉本斯：“那是一种高容量、当然也是高口径的枪。它是一把可怕的、绝对看起来很吓人的枪。”随着记者们急于寻找答案，调查不断深入。他们联系了朋友，收集了证据。随后警方发现了
the news of him, what's pretty much. He's a terrorist, he planned this entire attack, he left a threatening note in his car, there was ammunition. He was purchasing guns to either fund this attack or carry the attack out. They showed a table of guns that he never got, but that he wanted to actually buy at some point. It turned out Oletosan had actually ordered four guns off the internet, three of them low-caliber guns identical to one another, and the other was a 45 caliber Mach 10 semi-automatic. State's attorney Tom Gibbons. That is a high capacity, certainly a high caliber. It's a scary, certainly a scary-looking gun. As reporters pressed for answers, the investigation grew. Friends were contacted, evidence collected. Then police discovered
一些重要的事情。在调查过程中，电脑被扣押了。在他女朋友的电脑上发现了一个文件，那是他在一个叫Movie Maker的程序中创建的。他制作的是一个视频，里面有便条中发现的语言。这段语言写道：“还记得弗吉尼亚理工大学的混乱吗？好吧，你猜怎么着？它将在2007年6月再次发生，除非本视频的观众在以下PayPal账户中集体存入总计20万美元。”
something important. During the investigation there were computers seized. And something that was located on his girlfriend's computer was a file that he had created in a program called Movie Maker. And what he had made was a video with this language that was found in the note. It was language that read, do you remember the chaos at Virginia Tech? Well, guess what? It's going to happen again in June 2007, unless the viewers of this collectively deposit a total of $200,000 in the following PayPal account.
“否则，在目标大学的暑期学期里，被杀害的学生人数将超过弗吉尼亚理工大学。这不是个玩笑。”汤姆·吉本斯告诉我，这段语言是在一个被删除的文件中找到的。如果视频被删除了，你们怎么知道里面有什么？“嗯，因为电脑上的东西从来没有真正被完全删除过。我们的取证人员能够进入系统，
Or else, the number of students killed in Virginia Tech will be topped during the summer school semester at a target university. This is not a joke. Tom Gibbons told me that the language was found in a file that had been deleted. If the video was deleted, how did you know what was in it? Well, because nothing has ever really completely deleted off a computer. Our forensic examiners were able to go in,
在确保硬盘安全后对其进行镜像，并提取和分析硬盘上保留的所有数据。”2007年7月24日，奥莱托孙·奥德瓦莱被正式指控在校园宿舍藏有武器，以及一项严重得多的罪名——企图发出恐怖威胁。案件的实质是指控他构建了这一威胁。他正计划利用这个威胁付诸行动。要么是这样，要么他是在试图勒索金钱。这是一个奇怪的罪名——企图发出威胁。但由于检察官无法证明该威胁实际上已经传达给了任何人，
take an image of the hard drive after securing it, and extract and do an analysis of all the data that remains on a hard drive. On July 24, 2007, Oletos and Odehuale was formally charged with storing a weapon in campus housing, and a far more serious crime attempting to make a terrorist threat. The case that was made was effectively that he had constructed this threat. He was planning to use this threat either to act upon it. It was either that or he was trying to extort money. It was a strange charge and attempt to make a threat. But since prosecutors couldn't prove that threat had actually been communicated to anyone,
这已经是他们能做到的最好的了。“我要说的是，只有一个步骤缺失了，是我们无法证实的，那就是该威胁的实际公开发布。那是我们唯一缺少的最后一块证据，有了它，这将成为一个完整的恐怖威胁。”但汤姆认为他们有大量证据证明策划、准备和购买枪支的行为。“这有点像阴谋类的案件。它不完全是阴谋，但在同一脉络上，一个人正在为犯罪的实施采取实质性的具体步骤。通过这样做，他实际上就是在试图实施犯罪。”我问汤姆，这是否就像某人研究如何雇佣杀手但
that was the best they could do. I would say that there was only one step missing that we couldn't prove, and that was the actual public posting of the threat. That was the only last piece of evidence that we didn't have that would have made it a completed terrorist threat. But Tom felt they had plenty of proof showing planning, preparation, and effort to purchase firearms. It's like a conspiracy type of case. It's not exactly conspiracy, but in the same vein, a person is taking actual substantial steps toward the commission of the offense. And by doing that, they are in effect attempting to commit it. I asked Tom if this was like someone who does some research on how to hire a hitman, but
没有付诸行动一样？“嗯，我会把它比作那种拿着枪、开车去预期受害者的家，但无论出于什么原因，没有下车的人。但他们已经为这一行为、为谋杀采取了实质性的具体步骤。这不仅仅是想想而已。这不仅仅是一点点研究。这其中有相当大的一部分工作
doesn't act on it. Well, I would liken it more to the person who takes the gun, drives to the intended victim's house, and for whatever reason, doesn't get out of the car. But they've taken an actual substantial step toward the act, toward the murder. It's more than just thinking about it. It's more than just a little bit of research. There was a substantial amount of work
投入到了这上面。”所以我喜欢你刚刚的比喻，我很好奇从法律角度来看，你如何处理这种情况，因为假设某人确实买了一枪，也确实开车去了某人的家，但没有下车又把车开走了。假设有关部门通过某种途径知道了这一切的发生。你能以犯罪罪名起诉这个人吗？在谋杀的语境下，不能。在发出威胁的语境下，你也不能，因为他们正在采取实际步骤，他们在创造东西，他们在制造威胁。
that went into this. So I like the analogy that you have just now, and I'm curious sort of from a legal perspective, what you do with that, because let's say someone does buy a gun and does drive to someone's house and doesn't get out of that car and drives off. And let's say the authorities have some way of knowing about all of this happening. Can you charge that person with a crime? In the murder context, no. In the threatening context, you can't, because they're taking actual steps, they're creating things, they're creating the threat.
在汤姆·吉本斯看来，一场灾难被避免了。但真的如此吗？为了弄清楚真相，我动身去见那个被警方描述为危险的、潜在恐怖分子的人。请不要走开。今天，我们将讲述一个年轻人被指控企图发动恐怖袭击的故事，那个年轻人就是奥莱托孙·奥杜瓦莱（Oletosan Oduwale）。这是一个尼日利亚名字，但它赋予了一个在密苏里州圣路易斯出生并长大的男孩。“你知道，小时候我和我的兄弟们还有邻居里的朋友们，我们经常在后院玩。我们会去树林里
In Tom Gibbons' mind, a catastrophe had been averted. But had it? To find out, I went to meet the man who police described as a dangerous, would-be terrorist. Stay with us. Today the story of a young man accused of an attempted terrorist attack, that young man is Oletosan Oduwale. It's a Nigerian name, but it was given to a boy who was born and raised in St. Louis, Missouri. You know, as a kid me and my brothers and our friends in the neighborhood, we used to play in our backyard. We used to go out into the woods
玩捉迷藏、警察抓小偷之类的游戏，我们还在整个社区里骑自行车。”奥莱托孙的父母年轻时离开尼日利亚，移民到了美国。托森（Tosan，人们这样叫他）和他的五个兄弟一起在圣路易斯的一栋六居室房子里长大。他被音乐包围着，有数不清的音乐。“我大概在七八岁时就爱上了音乐。你知道，我听着很多德瑞博士（Dr. Dre）、史努比狗狗（Snoop Dogg）的歌长大，听了很多西海岸的音乐。我也有点喜欢声名狼藉B.I.G.（Biggie）和纳斯（Nas），但大部分还是西海岸的音乐。”托森这里所说的，是直接来自洛杉矶的90年代风格匪帮说唱。像德瑞博士和史努比狗狗这样的年轻人们，
and play hide and seek and cops and robbers and all that good stuff and we used to ride our bikes all throughout the neighborhood. Oletosan's parents left Nigeria and emigrated to the United States when they were young. Tosan, as he was called, was raised with his five brothers in a six-bedroom house in St. Louis. He was surrounded by music, lots and lots of music. I fell in love with music probably around 7 or 8 years old. You know, I grew up listening to a lot of Dr. Dre, Snoop Dogg, a lot of West Coast music. I'm a little bit of like biggy and nods, but majority West Coast music. What Tosin is talking about here is 90 style gangster rap straight out of LA. Young men like Dr. Dre and Snoop Dogg were writing
正将他们的才华转化为巨星地位。匪帮说唱是从嘻哈音乐中演变而来的。它长期以来一直备受争议，因为它强调匪帮生活方式，有时还宣扬暴力、厌女、毒品和谋杀。但它很受欢迎，在商业上也极其赚钱。对于像托森这样的孩子来说，它具有磁石般的吸引力。他完全沉浸其中。在八年级时，具体来说是在八年级，我和我的许多朋友开始在午餐桌上进行即兴说唱，有人在桌子上打拍子，大家围成一圈即兴说唱，你知道的，我们有七八个人。我们每天都这样做，真的是每天都这样做。这里面有很多粗俗的话，很多……
their talent into stardom. Gangster rap evolved from hip hop. It's long been controversial because it emphasizes the gangster lifestyle and at times promotes violence, misogyny, drugs and murder. But it's popular and commercially very lucrative. For a kid like Tosun, it was magnetic. He was all in. In eighth grade, specifically, it was in eighth grade. Me and a lot of my friends were used to start like wrapping at the lunch table with freestyle and some I would do the beat on the table, and be just going to circle just freestyle, you know, and it'd be like seven or eight of us. And we would do this every single day, literally every single day. And it was just a lot of, you know, profanity, a lot of just,
好吧，我们终于可以畅所欲言了，给我举个例子。好吧，UGK（Underground Kingz）有一首歌叫《Take It Off》，在95到98年左右非常非常火。所以那是一首非常非常火的歌。你是怎么唱的？你在当场考我。《Take It Off》是这样的：“Trick, Band, Dover, Lemme See It...”差不多这样。你12岁的时候就学会了这个？
okay, we can finally say what we want to say and give me an example. Okay, so UGK has a song called Take It Off, which was really, really big around like 95 to 98. And so that was a really, really big song. How did you go? You're playing me on the spot. It was Take It Off, Trick, Band, Dover, Lemme See It, If You're Cooking For A Trial Site, Nigga Lemme Beac, At The V-Twell Bins, Park Down12 being parked outside Ain't no room to put them bills in my ride Something like that You learned this when you were 12?
哦，对，绝对的。所以这首歌伴随你很长时间了吗？哦，当然，这是我小时候最喜欢的组合之一。托森说，那些脏话和硬派言谈并不是重点。音乐本身才是打动他的东西。比如节奏、贝斯、鼓、镲片，那种感觉，就只是一种感觉。我认为真正让人被音乐吸引、以及音乐如何让他们产生感觉的是这些。因此，嘻哈音乐本身，我的意思是，即使你不是那种文化的人，嘻哈
Oh yeah, definitely And so this has stayed with you for a long time Oh of course, that's one of my most favorite, favorite groups of one house a kid. Tosun says the swearing and tough talk, that wasn't really the point. The music itself was what moved him. Like the rhythm, the bass, the drums, the high hats, it was kind of like, it was just like a feel. I think what really makes people gravitate towards music and how it makes them feel. And so hip-hop itself, I mean, even if you're not in this way from the culture, hip-hop
也会带给你某种特定的感觉。它让你感到强大、虚张声势、自由，它让你感到充满创造力。托森曾有一个梦想，也许有一天他能作为说唱明星扬名立万。但当他14岁时，他的父亲把他送到国外上学，先是去了英国，然后去了尼日利亚。现在这可能看起来不是对一个有抱负的说唱艺人最好的安排，但托森说他的尼日利亚寄宿学校里到处都是像他一样的人。“所以我周围有很多人来自新泽西、纽约、亚特兰大、加利福尼亚和伦敦，他们很多人都做音乐。所以在尼日利亚时，我们在宿舍里经常做的一件事就是写说唱音乐。我想正是在尼日利亚，我
makes you feel a certain way. It makes you feel strong, braggadocious, free, it makes you feel creative. Tosin had a dream that maybe someday he could make a name for himself as a rap star. But when he was 14, his father sent him abroad for school, first to England and then to Nigeria. Now that might not seem the best move for an aspiring rap artist, but Tosin says his Nigerian boarding school was full of kids like him. So I was surrounded around a lot of people from New Jersey, New York, Atlanta, California, and London, and a lot of them made music. And so a lot of what we used to do in Nigeria when we were in the dorms is that we would write rap music. And I think it was in Nigeria where I
真正变得有创意、水平更高了，因为我们能够真正地专心致志。在美国，我一天只有七个小时和学校的朋友在一起。在尼日利亚，我三个月里一天24小时都和他们在一起。你知道，所以，是的，我大概就是在非洲时更加爱上它的。”正是在尼日利亚，托森作为说唱歌手完成了他的公开首秀。在教堂里，他去了一所基督教学校，每个星期天全校都会去教堂。
really really got, I guess, like creative and better and because we were able to just really lock in. In America, I was only with my friends at school seven hours a day. Nigeria, I'm with the 24 hours a day for three months. You know, and so it was, yeah, it was where I guess I fell in love with it more was when I was in Africa. It was in Nigeria that Tosan made his public debut as a rapper. In church, he went to a Christian school and each Sunday the entire school went to church.
那是一个巨大的教堂。有时他们会让教堂的学生在舞台上唱歌，或者进行某种表演，我们决定表演说唱。在整个会众面前进行基督教说唱。有2500人。当托森讲述这个故事时，你能从他对那一刻的回忆中听到他的喜悦。“我拿着麦克风冲上舞台，每个人都在……每个人都在赞美你，然后我开始说唱。没人听清我说了什么，但他们都疯狂了，这可是在教堂啊。这真的滋养了我的虚荣心，我想，天哪，人们爱我。人们爱我，你知道的，不管怎样，这只是教堂。”
It was a huge church. Sometimes they would allow students from the church to either sing songs on stage or do what a performance is, we decided to do a rap. A Christian rap in front of the entire congregation. Twenty-,500 people. When Toastin tells the story, you can hear his happiness just remembering that moment. I run on stage with the mic and everybody's like, and everybody's like praising you and then I start a rap. Nobody heard what I said, but they were going crazy and it was like this is a church. I really fed my ego, I go, man, people love me. The people love me, you know, like whatever, it's just church.
但这确实是一个建立自信的过程，就好像，好吧，你可以把你的说唱带出你的朋友圈子，真正在公众面前说出来。当托森在尼日利亚读高中最后一年时，他申请去美国上大学。他心里只有一所学校：南伊利诺伊大学。它吸引他的原因是离圣路易斯很近，离他的家人、朋友和
But that was really really, I guess, a confidence builder, as far as I'm okay, you can take your wraps away from just your circle of friends and actually like, say them to the public. When Tosin was in his last year of high school in Nigeria, he applied to go to college in the United States. He had only one school in mind, southern Illinois University. It appealed to him because it was close to St. Louis, close to his family, his friends,
家很近。他被录取了。2005年秋天，他开始了大学新生生涯。托森将其描述为对大学生活相当典型的初体验：上课、派对，学生们总是成群结队地一起活动。到了春季，托森决定加入一个兄弟会。他选择了非裔历史兄弟会阿法·斐·西塔（Alpha Phi Theta）并被其接受。托马斯·菲利普斯通过兄弟会认识了托森。
his home. He was accepted. In the fall of 2005, he started his freshman year. Tosin describes it as a pretty typical introduction to college life, classes, parties, students always moving together in huge groups. In the spring, Tosin decided to join a fraternity. He chose and was accepted by Ayoda Phi Theta, an historically African-American frat. Thomas Phillips met Tosin through the fraternity.
他记得自己对托森的第一印象，因为托森很引人注目。“他个子小小的，穿着一件巨大的连帽衫，戴着最大的耳机。复古耳机。”你知道80年代刚推出家用立体声耳机时的样子吗？那种巨大的、带垫子的耳罩，两侧带有金属支架。那不是你平时会戴出门的那种耳机，你可能会在自己家的舒适环境中用这种耳机听音乐。但不知为什么，一副那样的耳机，加上他当时那么小的个子，让我印象深刻。事实证明，他对音乐非常狂热，尤其是
He remembers his first glimpse of him because Tosin stood out. He was a little bit of a kid wearing a gigantic hoodie and the biggest headphones. Vintage headphones. So do you know back in the 80s when they first had the home stereo headphones that were like the big gigantic cushion pairs with the metal braces on the sides. Like once you would necessarily wear out in public, you might listen to like these headphones in the comfort of your own home. But something about those headphones and him being as small as he was then kind of stuck out to me. So as it turned out, he was really big in the music, especially
说唱音乐。那是他当时能找到的音质最好的耳机。两人成了好朋友。托马斯说托森心地善良。他很照顾别人。他经常请兄弟会的兄弟们帮他探望当地的无家可归者。他组织校园活动，包括邀请前黑豹党成员鲍比·西尔（Bobby Seale）发表演讲。他用音乐把人们凝聚在一起。正是音乐让他非常契合这个兄弟会。“当时，我们兄弟会的大多数人至少都有某种音乐才华，如果你不演奏乐器，你就会唱歌，如果你不会唱歌，你就会说唱。如果你这三样都不会——我就是这样，那你要么是个制作人，要么是个混音师。”
rap music. And that was the best pair of headphones he could find at the time. They gave him the best sound quality. The two became good friends. Thomas S. Tosin was big-hearted. He looked out for people. He often asked fraternity brothers to help him check up on the homeless in the area. He organized campus events, including a speech by former black panther Bobby Seal. And he drew people together with his music. It was music that made him such a good fit for the fraternity. At the time, most of us in the fraternity at least had some kind of musical talent, like if you didn't play instrument, you sung, if you couldn't sing, you rap. If you couldn't
托森当然是说唱歌手。托马斯是制作人。他们开始讨论要干出一番大事业。当托马斯向我描述那些日子时，他说理解托森有一点很重要。他的音乐对他意味着一切，但音乐并不代表他本人。
do any of the three, which I can't, then you were either a producer or a mixer. Tosin, of course, rapped. Thomas produced. They started talking about making it big. As Thomas describes those days to me, he says it's important to understand one thing about Tosin. His music meant everything to him, but it wasn't him.
所以，我注意到的一件事是，尽管托森的个性、他真正的个性通过他的行动表现出来，但他的音乐却完全不同。托森确实很喜欢带有暴力和厌女歌词的歌曲，但这并不意味着他是一个暴力或厌女的人。他当时最喜欢的组合之一是三六帮（Three 6 Mafia）。我不确定你是否熟悉他们，但他们当时的大部分音乐基本上就是摇滚乐的某种版本，有点像性与毒品那种调调。
So, one of the things that I did notice was that as much as Tosin, his personality, his actual personality came through in his actions, his music was entirely different. Tosin did relish songs with violent and misogynistic lyrics, but that didn't mean that he was a violent or misogynistic person. One of his favorite groups at the time was B6 Mafia. I'm not sure if you're familiar with them or not, but a lot of their music at the time was pretty much the version of rock and roll was like six and drugs kind of deal.
最终托马斯和托森决定一起合租。他们在离校园不远的地方找到了一间破旧的两居室公寓。托马斯说这太完美了。意思是，如果你想写关于你的生活有多艰难、你所在的地区有多少犯罪的说唱。你想唱关于真实的东西。这里就是你真正可以做到的地方。而且感觉很真实，因为你不是在圣路易斯的某个好公寓里录音，
Eventually Thomas and Tosen decided to move in together. They found a ratty to bedroom apartment not far from campus. Thomas says it was perfect. Meaning, like, if you want to wrap about, you know, how hard your life is and how, you know, there's a lot of crime in your area. And you want to wrap about what's real. Like, this is the place that you can actually do it. And it feels authentic because you're not actually recording this from, you know, you
你知道的，不是在酒店、顶层公寓或豪华录音室里录音。我们在地下室。到处都是蟑螂，我们在壁橱里录音。你知道的，因为我们的工作室在客厅里。客厅里有一个用来挂大衣的壁橱。当有客人来时，你拿他们的外套，把它们放进壁橱里。我们把那个壁橱改造成了一个录音棚隔间。所以我们的话筒就在里面。我们在墙上贴满了泡沫隔音材料，这就是那个录音棚隔间。公寓里的话筒就在里面，我们在墙上贴满了泡沫隔音材料，这就是那个录音棚隔间。这间公寓成了一个说唱沙龙，或者用托森的话说，一个艺术家的巢穴。事情就是这样。客厅里到处都是纸片和笔记本，一张沙发、一台电视、
know, a nice apartment in St. Louis someplace. You know, recording this in a hotel or in a penthouse or a nice recording studio. We're in the basement. There are roaches everywhere and we record this in the closet. You know, because our studio was in the living room. There was a closet in the living room which was four coats. Like, no one you have guests come, you take their coats, you put them in the closet. We turned that closet into a studio booth. So our microphone was in there. We put foam all over the walls to kind of soundproof it and that was the studio booth. The apartment microphone was in there, we put foam all over the walls to kind of soundproof it, and that was the studio booth. The apartment became a rap salon, or as Tosin puts it, an artist's den. And so that was how it was. It was pieces of paper and notebooks everywhere in the living room, a couch, a TV,
一台电脑、录音设备、麦克风、键盘，这就是我们的……我们的……我们的……我们的空间。他们在实验、写作、重写，试图创作出行的通的歌曲。他们在校园里演出过几次。有时他们分发免费CD来打响名气。但资金总是很紧张，他们需要更好的设备。托森认为自己是个企业家。他自豪地指出他来自一个白手起家的家庭。所以他说他开始寻找赚点外快机会。他想到了一个主意，回想起来，这可能不是最好的主意。它涉及到互联网和枪支。
a computer, studio equipment, microphone, keyboard, and that was our... our... our... our... our space. They were experimenting, writing, rewriting, trying to compose songs that worked. They played a couple of gigs on campus. Sometimes they handed out free CDs to get their name out. But money was always tight, and they needed better equipment. Tosin views himself as an entrepreneur. He proudly points out that he came from a family of self-starters. So he says he started looking for opportunities to make some extra cash. He landed on an idea, one that in retrospect might not have been the best. It involved the internet and guns.
所以我在想，好吧，你知道的，也许这可以是一项初级生意，我可以从网上的制造商那里非常便宜地买到这些枪，把它们运给当地的枪械经销商，然后再以零售价转售，赚一点小钱，我们可以用这笔钱购买我们梦寐以求的所有设备、录音设备，因为这是在前六七个月里一直困扰我们的一件事。我们用来录制音乐的设备太糟糕了。里面有太多的杂音，我们知道我们需要更好的设备。托森想到的这套模式叫做代发货（dropshipping）。它在网络销售中经常使用。当你在线从零售商处购买产品时，该产品不一定在零售商的仓库里。有时零售商必须从批发商那里订购。
And so I was thinking, okay, you know, maybe this could be a beginner business where I could buy these guns very cheap from the manufacturers online, have them shipped to a vocal dealer, and then resell them for retail price and make a little bit of money and we could use this money and buy all the equipment, studio equipment that we could dream of because that was one thing that was kind of harming us our first six or seven months. The equipment that we were recording music with was very bad. It was just, you know, the final songs, they'd be a lot of static and we just knew we needed better equipment. What Tosin was thinking of is called drop shipping. It's used all the time in online sales. When you buy a product online from a retailer, that product isn't necessarily sitting in the retailer's warehouse. Sometimes the retailer has to order it from a wholesaler.
你为一件零售商并没有实体拥有的产品付了钱。托森认为他可以把这种模式应用到网络枪械市场。批发购买枪支，然后加价转售。基本的商业理念就是低买高卖，就这么简单。托森在网上发布了枪支销售广告。一旦有人买下它们，他就从批发商那里订购枪支。但对于枪械销售来说，有个条件。批发购买的枪支必须经过持牌枪械经销商，
You've paid for a product the retailer doesn't physically possess. Tosin thought he could adapt this model to the online gun market. Buy Guns wholesale and then mark up the price. The basic business idea was by low sell high period. Tosin advertised guns for sale online. Once people bought them, he ordered the guns from the wholesaler. But with gun sales, there's a catch. Guns bought wholesale must go through a licensed gun dealer
然后才能转交给买家。托森并不担心这一点。他没有做任何违法的勾当。他联系了当地的枪械经销商，请他处理这笔交易。“所以这就是我一直在做的。你知道，我从来没有真正拥有过那些枪。我从没打算过。我也从来没这样做过。”托森承认他曾多次打电话给枪械经销商询问武器的事。但他这么做是因为，他说，他已经接受了买家的钱，需要完成这笔交易。
before they can pass on to a buyer. That didn't worry Tosin. He wasn't doing anything illegal. He contacted a local gun dealer and asked him to put through the transaction. And so that was what I was doing. You know, I never took possession of those guns. I never intended to. I never did. Tosin agrees that he called the gun dealer repeatedly to ask about the weapons. But that's because, he says, he had already accepted money from buyers and needed to complete the transaction.
所以，总结一下，我们有一个心怀大志的年轻人。他有着萌芽中的说唱歌手生涯、活跃的社交生活，并且热心社区服务。他在买枪，但他表示，这纯粹是为了转售并赚点外快来买音乐设备。这并不是一个潜在恐怖分子的形象，但这就让我们回到了警方在托森车里发现的那张纸条上，正如州检察官汤姆·吉本斯所说，他们发现，车里显眼处放着一张便条。一面写着音乐歌词，另一面却写着威胁。“把两美元寄到……”然后是一个PayPal账户。“如果在接下来的七天里，资金没有达到5万美元，那么将发生类似于弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案的血腥大屠杀，
So, to recap, we have a young man with big dreams. He's got a budding career as a rapper, an active social life, and a commitment to community service. He's buying guns, but only he says, to sell them and make a little extra cash for music equipment. This is not the picture of a would-be terrorist, but that brings us to that piece of paper that police found in Tosin's car, as state's attorney Tom Gibbons put it, they found, you know, visible in the car a note. It had music lyrics on one side, but a threat on the other. Send two dollars to, and then it's a PayPal account. If the money doesn't reach $50,000 in the next seven days, then a murderous rampage,
发生在另一所人口密集的大学，接着是大写字母：这不是个玩笑。”要解释这样一张索要赎金并威胁校园大屠杀的纸条很难不让人起疑。但托森说，问题在于一个词：便条。他坚称，警方发现的根本不是什么便条，而是为说唱歌曲胡乱涂鸦的构思。托森是这样描述这一切的发生过程的：
similar to the Virginia Tech shooting, will occur at another highly populated university, and then in all capital letters, this is not a joke. It would be hard to explain a way of note like this, demanding ransom threatening a campus massacre. But Tosun says the problem lies in one word. Note. What the police found, he insists, was not a note. It was scribbled ideas for a rap song. This is how Tosun says it all unfolded.
这一切始于艺术家里的一天深夜。托森刚看完电视剧《法律与秩序》（Law and Order）。那一集讲的是一些在社交媒体上直播他们家的博客。“所以是我，威洛。又见面了。你们很多人都对霍尔顿和我今天发生争执的视频发表了评论。”故事是这样开始的，当他们在直播、闲逛时，蒙面歹徒踹开门，绑架了女孩，殴打了她的男友，然后他们又回到女孩的网页上发出了勒索信息。托森对这一情节着迷了。
It began as an idea one night in the artist's den. Tosun had just finished watching the TV show, Law and Order. The episode was about some bloggers who live streamed their home on social media. So it's me, Willow. Again. A lot of you commented on the fight that Holden and I had me as today's video. And so the way the episode started off, while they were live streaming, just hanging out, masked men, kicking the door, kidnapped the girl, beat her up her boyfriend, and then later they get back on her online page and start a rancid. Tosun was fascinated by the episode.
他喜欢这种戏弄观众的方式。从头到尾，它都让人猜疑。他们是在网上看了一场真实的绑架事件吗？他们是在看行为艺术吗？托森认为这个前提可以作为说唱歌曲的一个很酷的口语引子。“所以这就是我想象这个点子的原因，我试图想出一些符合现实生活的东西。比如有PayPal，有YouTube，还有诸如此类的东西。”
He loved the way it played with viewers. All the way through, it kept people guessing. Were they watching an actual kidnapping take place online? Were they watching performance art? Tosun thought the premise might make a cool spoken introduction to a rap song. And so that was where the idea was trying to figure out something, I tried to figure out something that would be real to what's actually in life. Like there is PayPal and there is YouTube and there is etc etc.
所以这有点像对那种情节的模仿，但它不是那么虚假，而是真正现实的东西。有时说唱歌曲就是以这种方式开头的，用设置场景的引子加上不押韵的歌词。托森的朋友托马斯说，这正是他们当时在尝试的东西。你听过纳斯（Nas）专辑《It was written》的引子吗？我听过，是怎么样的？它以两个奴隶在……开始。这是在奴隶制时期发生的。所以，在美国历史中。所以，发生的事情是，这两个奴隶听到监工走近，他们决定
And so it was kind of like a copy of that but it's something that wasn't as fake as that. Something that was actually real. Sometimes rap songs start this way with introductions that set a scene with lyrics that don't rhyme. That, says Stoicin's friend Thomas, is what they were playing with. You heard the introduction to Nas's It was written? I have and how does it go? It starts off with two slaves in a few And this is said back in the slavery days. So, and American history. So, what happens is that the two slaves hear the overseer coming and they decide to stage
就在那个时刻发起一场起义。“该死的主人，你知道奴隶们在起义被平息后被拖走了。”所以是引子把你吸引进去，你听到这个暴力的引子，然后主歌就进来了。托森在想，索要赎金和校园枪击威胁的要求是否可以作为一个很好的引子。
in a revolt right at that point. Damn you master, you know the slaves being dragged away once the revolt is pretty much quilled at that point. So it's the introduction that draws you in, and you hear this violent introduction, and then the lead song comes on. Tosin wondered whether the demand for a ransom and the threat of a campershooting could make for a good intro.
朋友们把玩着这个创意，尝试了几种不同的东西。他们在纸上写了一些歌词。他们甚至制作了一个歌词视频，让歌曲的单词在屏幕上滚动。托森觉得这行不通，但他写在纸另一面的某些行最终确实变成了一首歌。这首歌叫《Pop It Mommy Pop It》。这是一首俱乐部风格的歌。它是关于女孩们在俱乐部跳舞的。我从头到尾把它完整地写了下来。
The friends played with the idea and tried out a few things. They wrote some lyrics on a piece of paper. They even made a lyric video where the words of a song scroll on the screen. Toson felt it didn't work, but some of the lines he wrote on the other side of the paper did eventually become a song. It was called pop it mommy pop it. It's like a club song. It's about like girls dancing in a club. I wrote it complete from beginning to end.
朋友们琢磨着这个主意，尝试了几样东西。他们在纸上写了一些歌词。他们甚至做了一个歌词视频，歌词在屏幕上滚动。托森觉得这行不通，但他写在纸另一面的一些台词最终确实变成了一首歌。这首歌叫《pop it mommy pop it》。它就像一首夜店歌曲。讲的是女孩们在夜店跳舞的事。我从头到尾把它完整地写了下来。
The lyrics on the other side of the paper were the ones that Tosin discarded. It was the reference to the Virginia Tech shootings, the threat of a mass killing. When Tosin decided to move back to campus sometime later, he threw all his notebooks and paper and clothes into his car to move them to a dorm. One sheet of paper slipped under the center console. It was the sheet police would later find in his car. Tosun says the police simply had him wrong. He wasn't a terrorist in the making. He was a student, a musician, a budding entrepreneur. He left his car on a campus side road for
纸另一面的歌词是托辛丢弃的部分。那是对弗吉尼亚理工大学枪击案的引用，也是关于大规模杀戮的威胁。后来当托辛决定搬回校园时，他把所有的笔记本、纸张和衣服都扔进车里，准备搬进宿舍。有一张纸滑到了中控台底下。就是这张纸，后来被警方在他的车里找到。托辛说，警察完全误解了他。他并不是一个正在成长的恐怖分子。他是一个学生、一个音乐家、一个崭露头角的企业家。他把车停在校园的一条路边，因为
a simple reason. He'd run out of gas. He says he was going to get more fuel when he got paid at the end of the week. And that loaded gun in his dorm? Tosun agrees he shouldn't have had the gun in campus housing. But he insists it was an innocent mistake. He'd legally registered the weapon and thought that that made it okay to have it with him on campus. Both Tosun and his friend Thomas say owning guns was not unusual
原因很简单。他的车没油了。他说，等周末拿到工资后，他就会去加满油。至于宿舍里那支上膛的枪？托辛承认，他不应该把枪放在校园宿舍里。但他坚称这是一个无心的错误。他已经合法注册了这把武器，并认为这意味著他可以随身带到校园里。托辛和他的朋友托马斯都说，拥有枪支并不罕见
in their part of the Midwest. It just wasn't a big deal. One of the things that I kind of want to like make sure that everybody's clear on is that down in Southern Illinois and St. Louis, Missouri area and all that, there was a pretty big gun culture so when we moved off campus one of the things that he mentioned that he wanted to do and that we both ended up doing was applying for our void cards. The firearm identification that Illinois has, you have to get an ID to own or carry a firearm.
在他们所在的美国中西部。这根本算不上什么大事。我想确保大家都清楚的一点是，在伊利诺伊州南部、密苏里州圣路易斯以及所有这些地区，有着相当浓厚的枪支文化，所以当我们搬出宿舍时，他提到的一件他想做、而且我们俩最终都去做了的事情，就是申请我们的 FOID 卡。也就是伊利诺伊州的枪支识别证，你必须获得一张身份证才能拥有或携带枪支。
Thomas and Toaston both say they had no idea the police were poking around. So when the cops burst into their dorm and arrested Toaston, it came as a complete surprise. So as far as in my mind, I'm thinking, okay, maybe I have a warrant for a ticket or a, I really didn't know what was going on. And so I asked them several times that, hey, can I call my dad? Like, I'm gonna call my dad just to let him know what was going on. And so I asked him several times that, hey, can I call my dad? Like, I'm gonna call my dad just to let him know what's going on. And can I call my older brother?
托马斯和托辛都说，他们根本不知道警察在到处调查。所以当警察突然闯入他们的宿舍并逮捕托辛时，这让他们感到完全意外。所以就我而言，我在想，好吧，也许我有一张交通罚单的逮捕令，或者别的什么，我真的不知道发生了什么。于是我问了他们好几次，嘿，我能给我爸爸打个电话吗？就像，我要给我爸爸打电话，只是为了让他知道发生了什么。于是我问了他们好几次，嘿，我能给我爸爸打个电话吗？就像，我要给我爸爸打电话，只是为了让他知道发生了什么。我能给我哥哥打电话吗？
And they wouldn't let me make any phone calls. He says it wasn't until a couple of days later when Thomas came to visit that he actually began to understand what was going on. So I picked up the phone and we were talking to him through the glass. And the first thing he asked me was, how am I? I said, I'm fine, and I'm just trying to figure out what's going on. And then that's when he says, do you remember that night
但他们不让我打任何电话。他说，直到几天后托马斯来探视时，他才真正开始明白发生了什么。于是我拿起电话，我们隔着玻璃和他说话。他问我的第一件事就是，我怎么样？我说，我很好，我只是在弄清楚到底发生了什么。然后就在那时他说，你还记得那天晚上吗
when we were writing and producing, and you wrote the thing about the PayPal account? And the thing we got from the law and order episode, and I was like, yeah. And then he says, that's what this is about. And so when he said that twice, he said, that's what this is about. Toaston Wari, they thought he was a terrorist and then came to charge for attempted terrorist threat. I never heard of a charge like that before. You know, attempted terrorist threat.
当我们在创作和制作时，你写了关于那个 PayPal 账户的事情？还有我们从《法律与秩序》那一集中获得的内容，我说，对。然后他说，这就是原因所在。所以当他重复了两遍这句话，他说，这就是原因所在。托辛·奥杜瓦莱，他们认为他是个恐怖分子，然后以企图制造恐怖威胁的罪名起诉他。我以前从未听说过这样的罪名。你知道，企图制造恐怖威胁。
Not a terrorist threat. Still, Tosun was sure the confusion would soon be cleared up. So as my dad gets here with our lawyer, we'll be able to explain this, and you know, and that'll be the end of it. They made a mistake and we can go back to our lives. Well, when the story hit the news, Tosun says everything got warped. They were saying a Nigerian citizen, Olu Tosun Oduhale, and making it seem like I was like a foreigner
不是恐怖威胁。尽管如此，托辛确信这场误会很快就会澄清。所以只要我爸爸带着我们的律师来到这里，我们就能够解释清楚这一切，你知道的，事情就会这样结束。他们犯了个错误，我们可以回到我们的生活中去。然而，当这个故事登上新闻时，托辛说一切都被扭曲了。他们说一个尼日利亚公民，奥卢托辛·奥杜瓦莱，把搞得我好像是个外国人
that came over here, just the way I was being portrayed as if I was a terrorist. And of course, my name was mispronounced on purpose to make it sound really, really foreign and just different. And they were not describing me like I was a kid born and raised in St. Louis, Missouri. The news media kept harping on the note. They distorted it, Tosun says. And so, yes, when you now paint it that way as a note and violence and guns, it's very
来到这里，我被塑造的方式就好像我是一个恐怖分子。当然，我的名字被故意发错音，听起来非常非常外国，非常与众不同。他们对我描述时，完全不像是一个在密苏里州圣路易斯出生长大的孩子。新闻媒体一直在那张纸上大做文章。托辛说，他们歪曲了事实。所以，是的，当你现在把它描绘成一张纸、暴力和枪支时，非常
easy to make anybody feel like, oh yeah, this was one bad guy, because you can craft information and make something appear the way you want to if you have the upper hand. Tosun says no one in law enforcement wanted to hear his side of the story. Thomas Phillips felt the same. After police initially talked to Thomas, he tried to go back to them and explain that they had it all wrong. It's a shame that I can actually tell somebody like a law enforcement official after the initial interview. This is what actually has happened. Can y'all add this to the story? And that no one's going to hear it because everybody's minds already made up with what actually appears to be the case. Why did that happen? There were lots of issues. Race, culture, the fear of a mass shooting, and there was the music. After we ran the analysis, we found that in every dimension, rap lyrics were evaluated
很容易让人觉得，哦，是的，这是一个坏人，因为如果你占据上风，你可以精心捏造信息，让事情呈现出你想要的样子。托辛说，执法部门没有人愿意听取他的说法。托马斯·菲利普斯也有同感。在警察最初与托马斯交谈后，他试图再次找到他们，解释他们完全搞错了。真遗憾，在初次讯问后，我居然能对执法官员这样的人说。这才是实际发生的事情。你们能把这个补充到报道中吗？然而没有人会听，因为所有人的脑海中都已经认定了事情表面上看起来的样子。为什么会这样？这里面有很多问题。种族、文化、对大规模枪击案的恐惧，还有音乐。在我们进行了分析之后，我们发现在各个维度上，与被认为是乡村音乐的歌词相比，说唱歌词受到的负面评价更多。
more negatively compared to when the lyrics were perceived to be country. Stay with us. A few months after Tosen was arrested, a visitor showed up to meet Jeffrey Ordangin, a professor and lawyer at Northwestern University Pritzker School of Law. The man was Toyan O'Dewale, Tosun's father. Toyan was unruffled and extremely poised and dignified. Tosun's father wanted Jeffrey to take on his son's case. He was intrigued and agreed.
请继续收听。托辛被捕几个月后，一位来访者来到西北大学普里茨克法学院拜访了教授兼律师杰弗里·奥丹根。这个人是托延·奥杜瓦莱，托辛的父亲。托延镇定自若，极其沉稳且有尊严。托辛的父亲希望杰弗里接手他儿子的案子。他感到很感兴趣，并答应了。
Jeffrey drove five hours south to see Tosun at the Madison County Jail. It was a contact visit because I was an attorney. And that was our first meeting. He was, if I recall, he was shackled at the ankles and handcuffed. It is wrists. And he was a quiet, young guy, great eye contact. Not particularly frightened, like so many people are in that situation.
杰弗里向南驱车五个小时，到麦迪逊县监狱探望托辛。因为我是律师，这是一次接触式会面。那是我们的第一次见面。如果我没记错的话，他脚上戴着脚镣，手上戴着手铐。在他的手腕上。他是一个安静的年轻人，眼神交流很好。并没有特别害怕，不像身处那种境地的人们那样。
In light of the Virginia Tech Massacre, Jeffrey says he understood why police suspected Tosin. But he says they should have quickly figured out that they were off track. Once you did your investigation, you should have known that you were off on a fool's errand. You should have known, and it wouldn't have taken too much effort to realize too much effort to realize that he was not plotting or planning some kind of massacre. You could have realized and seen very readily that these were lyrics. In fact, there were lyrics on the opposite side, if I recall of that note, on both sides. And I believe that there were lyrics recall of that note on both sides. And I believe that there were lyrics throughout the car
鉴于弗吉尼亚理工大学大屠杀，杰弗里说他理解为什么警方会怀疑托辛。但他说，他们本该很快发现自己走错了方向。一旦你做了调查，你就应该知道自己是在白忙一场。你本该知道，并且花不了多少精力就能意识到，花不了多少精力就能意识到他根本没有策划或计划任何形式的大屠杀。你本能意识到并且非常容易地看出这些都是歌词。事实上，如果我没记错的话，在那张纸的反面也有歌词，正反面都有。并且我相信
and his apartment when they searched it, they found notebooks with hundreds of pages of rap lyrics. Investigators were unable to find evidence that Tosin had a violent side. Teachers and students maintained he wasn't threatening. But the prosecution disagreed. State's attorney Tom Gibbon says, despite Tosin's insistence that what was on the paper were lyrics, he remains certain that they were not.
当他们搜查他的车和公寓时，他们在那里发现了记有数百页说唱歌词的笔记本。调查人员未能找到托辛拥有暴力倾向的证据。老师和学生们坚称他没有威胁性。但检方并不认同。州检察官汤姆·吉本表示，尽管托辛坚称纸上写的是歌词，但他依然确信这些并不是歌词。
I've probably read at least a thousand pages of his writing to get to know the mind of Oletosan Odeowani and to understand the difference between the types of writings that he did. And so, you know, having, and after reviewing all that, spending a lot of time looking at it, mostly in my free time at night, I became convinced that in fact, this was genuinely a crime. This was an individual planning, a very serious crime. This was not prosecuting someone for writing lyrics. This was prosecuting someone for writing lyrics.
我大概读了至少一千页他的写作，以了解奥卢托辛·奥杜瓦莱的心智，并理解他所创作的各种文体之间的区别。所以，你知道的，在拥有了这些之后，在审阅了所有这些、花了很多时间去研究之后，大部分是在我晚上的空闲时间里，我开始确信，事实上，这确实是一起犯罪。这是一个正在策划非常严重犯罪的个人。这不是在起诉一个人写歌词。这不是在起诉一个人写歌词。
This was prosecuting somebody for all of the substantial steps that he had taken toward very serious crimes and potentially a mass casualty event. So now we have two different stories. One is a tale of a potential terrorist plotting a campus massacre. Another is a story of a young man who has unlawfully stored a gun at his university,
这是在起诉某人为他为实施非常严重的犯罪以及潜在的大规模伤亡事件所采取的所有实质性步骤。所以现在我们有两个不同的故事。一个是潜在恐怖分子策划校园大屠杀的故事。另一个是一个年轻人非法在大学里藏枪的故事，
but otherwise has done little wrong. It would be up to a jury to decide which story was the truthful one and how to understand those words written on that piece of paper. But before we head to trial, I want to introduce you to one more person. My name is Sharis Kubrin and I'm a professor of criminology, Law and Society at the University of California Irvine. Sharis was called as an expert for the defense in Tosin's case, in part because of some interesting research she's done.
但除此之外，他并没有做错太多。陪审团将决定哪个故事才是真相，以及如何理解写在那张纸上的那些文字。但在我们进入庭审之前，我想向大家介绍另一个人。我叫沙里斯·库布林，我是加州大学欧文分校犯罪学、法律与社会学教授。沙里斯作为托辛案的辩护专家被传唤出庭，部分原因是因为她做过的一些有趣研究。
She was noticing a large number of prosecutions that were introducing rap lyrics in court. She had a basic question. Our violent lyrics perceived as more threatening, more dangerous, more literal, more in need of regulation, when they are described as rap compared to other music genres. This question, she felt, was intricately linked to the outcomes of criminal cases. Because prosecutors are using rap lyrics as evidence in these criminal trials, I felt this raises a whole host of questions about whether prosecutors, judges, jurors may be relying
她注意到有大量案件在法庭上引入了说唱歌词。她有一个基本的问题。当暴力歌词被描述为说唱时，与其它音乐流派相比，人们是否会认为它们更具威胁性、更危险、更字面化、更需要受到监管？她认为，这个问题与刑事案件的结果错综复杂地联系在一起。因为检察官在这些刑事审判中将说唱歌词用作证据，我觉得这引发了一系列的问题，关于检察官、法官、陪审团在解释和评估这些歌词时，是否可能依赖于对说唱歌手和说唱音乐的看法和刻板印象。
on perception and stereotype about rappers and rap music in their interpretation and evaluation of the lyrics. So Shara's devised a study. She pulled lyrics from a 1960s folk song. We identified a set of violent lyrics. It was actually lyrics from this song, Bad Man's Blunder. And it's a Kingston trio folk group from the 60s. And the lyrics go something like this.
于是沙里斯设计了一项研究。她从一首20世纪60年代的民歌中提取了歌词。我们确定了一组暴力歌词。实际上就是这首歌《坏蛋的失误》（Bad Man's Blunder）里的歌词。这是60年代的一个金斯顿三重唱民谣组合。歌词大致是这样的。
Well, early one evening, I was rolling around. I was feeling kind of mean. I shot a deputy down. Strolling on home and I went to bed., while I laid my pistol up under my head. Well early in the morning about the break of day, I figured it was time to make a get away. Stepping right along but I was stepping too slow, got surrounded by a sheriff down in Mexico. Well early in the morning about a break of day, I figured it was time to make a getaway. It was stepping right along, but I was stepping too slow, got surrounded by a share of down in Mexico.
好吧，傍晚时分，我四处游荡。我感觉有点刻薄。我开枪打死了一个副警长。溜达着回家，然后我上床睡觉，同时我把手枪放在我的头底下。好吧，清晨破晓时分，我想是时候逃跑了。大步流星地走着，但我走得太慢了，在墨西哥被一个治安官包围了。好吧，清晨破晓时分，我想是时候逃跑了。大步流星地走着，但我走得太慢了，在墨西哥被一个治安官包围了。
So we took this set of Vimant lyrics, and we told participants in our experiment that they were either rap lyrics or country music lyrics. Sharers then asked them how threatening and offensive they perceived the lyrics to be, and offensive they perceived the lyrics to be and whether they felt the lyrics should be regulated. And after we ran the analysis we found that in every dimension rap lyrics were evaluated more negatively compared to when the lyrics were perceived to be country.
于是我们采用了这组暴力歌词，并告诉我们实验的参与者，这些要么是说唱歌词，要么是乡村音乐歌词。沙里斯随后询问他们，他们觉得这些歌词有多大威胁性和攻击性，以及他们是否认为这些歌词应该受到监管。在我们进行了分析之后，我们发现在各个维度上，与被认为是乡村音乐的歌词相比，说唱歌词受到的负面评价更多。
Sharris then replicated the study. Again, she didn't play songs for volunteers. She just printed out the lyrics from a Johnny Cash song. Called Boining Sue. But I busted a chair right across his teeth and we crashed through the wall into the street. And by the way, Johnny Cash gets invoked a lot because everyone knows his song, I shot a man in Reno
沙里斯随后重复了这项研究。同样，她没有给志愿者播放歌曲。她只是打印出了一首约翰尼·卡什歌曲的歌词。名叫《名叫苏的男孩》。但我一椅子砸在他牙齿上，我们撞穿墙壁来到了街上。顺便说一句，约翰尼·卡什经常被提及，因为每个人都知道他的歌《我在里诺枪杀了一个人》
just to watch him die. And so Johnny Cash gets kind of invoked like, well, why can Johnny Cash say lyrics like that? Where he's shooting a man in Reno and there's other violence, but when rappers do it, it's seen as literal. But anyway, we selected these lyrics from a boy named Sue. Well, I hit him hard right between the eyes and he went down, but to my surprise. He came up with a knife and cut off a piece of my ear, but I busted a chair right across his teeth, and we crashed through the wall and into the street, kicking in a gouging in the mud and the blood in the beard. I tell you, I've called tough men, but I really can't remember when.
只为了看他死去。所以约翰尼·卡什有点被拿出来说事，比如，为什么约翰尼·卡什可以唱这样的歌词？他在里诺枪杀了一个人，还有其他暴力行为，但当说唱歌手这样做时，却被视为是字面意思。但无论如何，我们从《名叫苏的男孩》中挑选了这些歌词。嗯，我狠狠地打在他两眼之间，他倒下了，但令我惊奇的是。他掏出一把刀，割掉了我的一只耳朵，但我一椅子砸在他牙齿上，我们撞穿墙壁来到了街上，在泥土、血水和胡须中又踢又戳。我告诉你，我见过硬汉，但我真的记不清什么时候。
It kicked like a mule, and it bit like a crocodile. We found that those people who thought that those were rap lyrics were much more likely to evaluate them negatively on all those dimensions compared to those participants in our study who thought they were country. As a criminologist, Sharif says her results are troubling. I am not necessarily advocating to not find people guilty of a crime that they've committed. What I am advocating for is the use of proper techniques and proper evidence to arrive at that decision.
它像骡子一样踢人，像鳄鱼一样咬人。我们发现，那些认为这些是说唱歌词的人，与我们研究中认为这是乡村音乐的参与者相比，更有可能在所有这些维度上对它们给予负面评价。作为一名犯罪学家，沙里斯说她的结果令人不安。我并不是一定要主张不对那些犯了罪的人定罪。我主张的是使用正确的技术和正确的证据来做出这一决定。
Right now, prosecutors are relying too heavily on a form of artistic expression that is fictional, that has a lot of artistic conventions knowing full well that the vast majority of jurors and judges don't really know what the artistic conventions of rap music are. The prosecutors in this sense are taking shortcuts and it's at the expense of people's lives. And by the way, no other form of artistic expression is treated this way in the courts. Because it's not as if rock musicians and heavy metal musicians and punk musicians are having their lyrics introduced as evidence against them. This is happening only for rappers and rap music. On October 18, 2011, in Madison County, Illinois, Oletosan Odeoale's trial began.
现在，检察官过分依赖一种虚构的艺术表现形式，这种形式有很多艺术惯例，他们心知肚明绝大多数陪审团成员和法官并不真正了解说唱音乐的艺术惯例。从这个意义上说，检察官在走捷径，而代价是人们的生命。顺便说一句，在法庭上没有任何其他形式的艺术表现形式受到这种待遇。因为并不是说摇滚乐手、重金属乐手和朋克乐手的歌词被当作指控他们的证据。这种情况只发生在说唱歌手和说唱音乐身上。2011年10月18日，在伊利诺伊州麦迪逊县，奥卢托辛·奥杜瓦莱的审判开始了。
Jeffrey Ordangan says, things went wrong from the start. You know, Oletosan Odoale was a very dark skin night Jury and young man whose interest was rap and the whole defense was centered around rap. The jury was all white, overwhelmingly rural, and the average age was in the 40s and 50s. So if you put that profile together, a 50-year-old white rural juror trying to understand our defense, who none of them, if I recall, had ever listened with any frequency to rap music. Some of them did not know what it was, but this was the jury that we ended up with.
杰弗里·奥丹根说，事情从一开始就出了问题。你知道，奥卢托辛·奥杜瓦莱是一个皮肤非常黑的年轻人，他的兴趣是说唱，整个辩护都是围绕着说唱展开的。陪审团全是由白人组成，绝大多数来自农村，平均年龄在40到50岁之间。所以如果你把这个组合拼凑起来，一个50岁的乡村白人陪审团成员试图理解我们的辩护，据我回忆，他们当中没有一个人经常听过说唱音乐。他们中的一些人甚至不知道那是什么，但这就是我们最终得到的陪审团。
And so that was a problem. Tom Gibbons did not argue the case, but supervised the attorneys who did. He believes they acted with care and caution. I wanted to make absolutely sure that we weren't using the authority of the State's Attorney's Office to prosecute somebody for their thoughts, to prosecute somebody for, in this case, rap lyrics. That's not an appropriate use of the power of a prosecutor's office and the power of law enforcement. Again, much of the attention was focused on that piece of paper that police found in Tosin's car. Tom Gibbon says the defense argues trenawously
所以这是一个问题。汤姆·吉本没有亲自出庭辩护，而是监督了出庭的律师。他相信他们行事谨慎小心。我想要绝对确保我们没有利用州检察官办公室的权力去起诉某人的思想，去起诉某人在本案中写下的说唱歌词。这不是检察官办公室权力以及执法权力的恰当使用。同样，大部分注意力都集中在警察在托辛车里发现的那张纸上。汤姆·吉本说辩护方进行了强有力的辩论
that the writing was rap lyrics. Although I have to tell you, one of his lawyers tried to rap the words in this note in trial and it was a miserable failure because these are not rap lyrics. To this comment, Tosin just shakes his head. He admits the lyrics were not very good, which is why he didn't end up using them in a song.
这些文字是说唱歌词。虽然我必须告诉你，他的其中一位律师在庭审中试图说唱这便便条上的词，结果惨遭失败，因为这些根本不是说唱歌词。听到这个评论，托辛只是摇了摇头。他承认这些歌词写得不是很好，这也是为什么他最终没有在一首歌里使用它们的原因。
But they were still a rap. They didn't want to tell people it was rap music, they wanted to say it was a note. So they didn't show where it rhymed, where it actually rhymed. If you don't know rap music, and I just give you that sentence, where can you make it rhyme? It doesn't look like a rhyme. If this account doesn't reach 50,000, seven days, get ready for a murderous rampage.
但它们仍然是一首说唱。他们不想告诉人们这是说唱音乐，他们想说这是一张便条。所以他们没有展示押韵的地方，也就是它实际押韵的地方。如果你不懂说唱音乐，而我只给你那个句子，你在哪里能让它押韵？它看起来一点也不像押韵。如果这个账号在七天内没有达到五万粉，就准备迎接一场疯狂的大屠杀吧。
Simulair to the VT shooting will occur at A-Nother. Holly populated University, and this is not a joke. So if you don't know rap music, you won't be able to piece that together. Majority of southern Illinois, Midwestern people that are 40, 50, 60 years old, prosecute as police officers, they don't know how to break down rap news or anything. So when I said, hey, that was like a small piece of like a rap verse that we didn't even want to use, they like it out of here. He's lying.
类似于弗吉尼亚理工枪击案的事情将发生在另一个人口稠密的大学，这不是在开玩笑。所以如果你不懂说唱音乐，你就无法把它拼凑起来。伊利诺伊州南部的绝大多数人，40、50、60岁的中西部人，担任检察官或警察，他们不知道如何剖析说唱新闻或任何东西。所以当我说，嘿，那只是一小段说唱歌词，我们甚至都不想用它，他们就把它当回事了。他在撒谎。
After a five day trial, the jury returned its verdict guilty. States attorney Tom Gibbons, the jury convicted Mr. Odo Wally. They took all the evidence into account. They deliberated for I don't recall the amount of time. I think it was a couple hours at least. And they returned a verdict of guilty on both counts and he was sentenced to five years in the department of corrections on the uh... attempted terrorist threat and a year in the Madison county jail
经过五天的审判，陪审团给出了裁决：有罪。州检察官汤姆·吉本说，陪审团判处奥杜瓦莱先生有罪。他们考虑了所有的证据。他们进行了审议，具体时间我记不清了。我想至少有几个小时吧。他们对两项指控都做出了有罪的裁决，他被判处在惩教署服刑五年，罪名是企图制造恐怖威胁，并在麦迪逊县监狱服刑一年，
on the unauthorized possession of a weapon based on the the level of the offense jeffrey or dangen says the trial was a disaster. It was a first amendment train wreck in my view. Jeffrey sees two flaws in the prosecution's case. First, they criminalized speech. By taking a work of art, it's something that was intended as a work of art,
罪名是根据犯罪情节的严重程度非法持有武器。杰弗里·奥丹根说，这场审判是一场灾难。在我看来，这是一场宪法第一修正案的列车脱轨事故。杰弗里认为检方的案件有两个缺陷。首先，他们将言论刑事化。通过将一件艺术品，也就是原本打算作为艺术品的东西，
and distorted it into criminal intent. Second, he says, the criminalized thought. By criminalizing thought, what I mean is we need to charge this man with a crime because for all we know, he was thinking about acting on what we surmise were evil intense, even though we have no evidence that he intended to communicate that thought. Tosun says his worst moment came after the trial at the Graham Correctional Center. They strip you naked, they tell you to bend over, they make sure you don't, you know, you're not sneaking in any weapons, just a very degrading process. And then when they find, when they put me in a cell, and then they lock the door, and then you hear the clink, and it's a, it's
并将其歪曲为犯罪意图。其次，他说，他们将思想刑事化。通过将思想刑事化，我的意思是我们需要指控这个人犯罪，因为据我们所知，他在考虑根据我们推测的邪恶意图采取行动，尽管我们没有证据表明他打算传达这种思想。托辛说，他最糟糕的时刻是在庭审后关押在格雷姆惩教中心的时候。他们让你脱光衣服，叫你弯下腰，确保你没有，你知道的，没有偷偷携带任何武器，这是一个非常屈辱的过程。然后当他们发现，当我被关进一个牢房，然后他们锁上门，然后你听到咔哒一声，这是一个
a small cell. It's like five by nine. There's two metal bunk beds in there and it's you and another guy, and you just feel so claustrophobic, but you can't leave." Tosun says it felt like being punched in the gut. Jeffrey Ardangan appealed the conviction. A year and a half later, the case came before an appellate court. The conviction for the terrorist charge was overturned. The court said, in the absence of sufficient evidence that the defendant had taken a substantial step toward making a terrorist threat, his writings, as abhorrent as they might be, amount to mere thoughts.
一个狭小的牢房。大约五英尺乘九英尺。里面有两张金属双层床，里面只有你和另一个人，你会感到无比的幽闭恐惧，但你却无法离开。”托辛说，那感觉就像腹部挨了一拳。杰弗里·奥丹根对定罪提出了上诉。一年半后，此案提交给了一家上诉法院。针对恐怖主义指控的定罪被推翻了。法院表示，在缺乏充分证据证明被告已采取实质性步骤去发出恐怖威胁的情况下，他的文字无论多么令人反感，也只属于单纯的思想。
Since Stoson's case went to trial, there have been many other cases in which rap artists have had their lyrics introduced as evidence in criminal proceedings. Criminalologist, Charis Cubran. Not a lot of people know that this is happening. I don't think we quite understand the implications of using rap lyrics as evidence. And what that means for defendants. Like, can they get a fair trial? Can we ensure that their first amendment rights are protected when these lyrics have the potential to bias jurors?
自从托辛的案子开庭审判以来，还有许多其他案件中，说唱歌手的歌词被作为证据引入刑事诉讼程序。犯罪学家沙里斯·库布兰。没有多少人知道这件事正在发生。我认为我们并不完全理解将说唱歌词用作证据的含义。以及这对被告意味着什么。比如，他们能得到公正的审判吗？当这些歌词有可能使陪审团产生偏见时，我们能否确保他们的第一修正案权利得到保护？
When a medalist's home in New Jersey, Oletosan Oduwale was 31 years old. He says the trial, the conviction, the prison time, he's put all of that behind him. But one thing still upsets him. Having lyrics he considers embarrassingly bad, attached to his name. There's a lot of stuff that you will never hear, that you will never see, because I either didn't think it was good, or I didn't think it would be received well. This was supposed to be one of those things
在新泽西州的梅德尔斯家时，奥卢托辛·奥杜瓦莱31岁。他说，审判、定罪、监狱生活，他已经把这一切都抛在了脑后。但有一件事仍然让他心烦意乱。那就是拥有被他认为糟糕得令人尴尬的歌词，并且这些歌词还冠上了他的名字。有很多东西你永远不会听到，你也永远不会看到，因为要么我觉得它不够好，要么我觉得它不会受欢迎。这本该是那种
that the world was never supposed to see or hear. ... ... Every artist, aspiring or well-established, knows what it's like to try something and then toss it aside. The drawings are skew, the photograph is blurry, the verses don't rhyme. The cutting room floor is littered with false starts and failed attempts, but these dead ends and errors are essential to the artistic process.
这个世界永远不应该看到或听到。……每一个有抱负或成熟的艺术家，都知道尝试某些东西然后将其丢弃是什么滋味。画作歪了，照片模糊了，诗句不押韵。剪辑室的地上散落着错误的开始和失败的尝试，但这些死胡同和错误对于艺术创作过程至关重要。
Toaston never ended up becoming a rap star. He's still a musician, but he's more focused now on finishing his education, launching a career in real estate and starting a family one day. Some of Toaston's work did find the spotlight. People spent hours pouring over his music, analyzing his words. But like others before him, Toaston discovered that the artist doesn't always control how his creations are understood. Sometimes, the stuff on the cutting room floor ends up being your legacy.
托辛最终没有成为说唱明星。他仍然是一名音乐家，但他现在更专注于完成学业、开启房地产事业以及有朝一日组建家庭。托辛的一些作品确实找到了聚光灯。人们花了几小时研读他的音乐，分析他的歌词。但和以前的其他人一样，托辛发现艺术家并不总是能控制自己的作品被理解的方式。有时，剪辑室地上的那些东西最终成了你的遗产。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Raina Cohen, Jennifer Schmidt, and Tara Boyle. Our team includes Maggie Penman and Renee Clark. Original music for this episode was composed by Rampteen Arblui. A run sung hero this week is Mary Glendinning. Mary is a research librarian at NPR, and she played a crucial role in tracking down information for the story. When you picture a librarian, you're probably thinking of someone who deals with books. But Mary and her team are so much more than that. They are fact checkers, detectives, masters of the archives, and data experts.
本期《隐秘大脑》节目由莱娜·科恩、詹妮弗·施密特和塔拉·博伊尔制作。我们的团队成员包括玛吉·彭曼和雷妮·克拉克。本期的原创音乐由拉姆蒂恩·阿尔布鲁伊创作。本周的无名英雄是玛丽·格伦迪宁。玛丽是NPR的研究图书管理员，她在为这个故事追踪信息的过程中发挥了至关重要的作用。当你想象一个图书管理员时，你可能脑海中浮现的是一个与书籍打交道的人。但玛丽和她的团队远不止于此。他们是事实核查员、侦探、档案馆大师和数据专家。
Thank you Mary and all the researchers at NPR for your hard work. I'm Shankar Vedantanthum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，玛丽，以及NPR的所有研究人员，感谢你们的辛勤工作。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。